عندنا احنا معايير في النقدي معايير
الجميل والجليل او القبيح طبعا
حتى معيار الجوده والرداءه موجود هو من
مصطلحات النقديه لكن خارج المصطلحين ندخل
في امر بعيد تماما عن
المفهوم
الثقافي سواء كان فن او ادب وبالتالي
دائما مؤسسات التربويه والتعليميه
والاكاديميه تحاول ان تقدم المعيار سواء
للطلبه اللي يدرسون متلقين او حتى من يمكن
ان يكونوا اصحاب مواهب ثم يعني يبدعون في
مجالات الثقافه سواء الفن والادب او الفكر
فبالتالي يمكن ان يغيب وجود المؤسسه
التربويه وبالتالي هذا
يخل في المعيار في المجتمع بشكل عام مما
يجعل ان الفاسد الداخل مع الرديء حتى كاد
الاثنين يكونون بحري في الفاسد
طبعا هو كل ما يخالف المعايير الفنيه
الاساسيه سواء في القواعد او في العناصر
الفاسد هو الذي يعني يمنع وجود الاخر
الفاسد هو الذي يمارس نوع من العنف اللفظي
او المعنوي لوجود الاخر في الفن والادب
طبعا الذي يستخدم ايضا او يتقوى
بعناصر او
بنقول ادوات داعمه من اجل القضاء على
الجميل ايضا في الفنون والاداب وهذا يحدث
اوقات لمصالح ودوافع مختلفه طبعا وهذا
طبعا ينعكس فيما بعد على المتلقين فتخيل
جيل جيلين ثلاثه اربعه يتعودون على الفساد
في مفهومهم مثلا مثلا فن الرسم فن الغناء
فن تمثيل فبالتالي يعتقدونهم هذا الفاسد
هو المعيار وبالتالي يمتنع عليهم فرصه
التعرف على الاصول